demand
europe's biggest banks are told they
aren't doing enough to tackle the
climate crisis
and swapping private jets for public
transport in today's daily climate
debate we ask how viable it really is
for the music industry to become more
sustainable
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions and one of those solutions is
renewable energy but today its
limitations have once again come into
focus as a coal-fired power station was
needed to balance britain's electricity
supply and demand now that's despite a
government aim that the fossil fuel will
be phased out entirely over the next
three years let's take a look at our
data dashboard and at the very top you
can see the real-time power mix in great
britain and at the moment you can see 52
is coming from fossil fuels we've got 30
coming from renewable sources and we've
got 18 there coming from nuclear
so let's get more on this now with our
science correspondent thomas moore so
thomas is this a cause of a concern as
we transition away from fossil fuels
well it certainly shows the challenge
and coal is the dirtiest of all the
fossil fuels and that's why we have seen
long periods where we're not burning
coal anymore but this shows that coal is
not dead we still rely on it for peaks
and demand and this has happened because
of a perfect storm on one hand you've
got a spike in gas prices at the moment
because of a global supply crunch and
that means it becomes more economic to
fire up those uh coal powered fire
station fire stations again
but secondly you've also got a situation
where the wind really hasn't been
blowing today it's been very light this
morning about 500 megawatts was being
generated compare that to one day in may
where you had 14 000 megawatts
and although it's been a sunny day the
solar farms can't yet fill that gap and
that's why people have gone back to the
bad old fossil fuels and it shows two
things one consumers are likely to face
a spike in energy prices this winter
because of that
rise in global gas prices but secondly
it shows the challenge of moving the
grid over to
net zero decarbonizing it
that we need much more
green energy on a huge scale and that
would give us energy
energy security but also independence
from those fluctuating global gas prices
but importantly we also need to find a
way of storing energy not just from day
to day when we get these fluctuations in
generation capacity but also season to
season finding a way of holding that
energy in the summer the autumn the
spring and using it in the winter when
demand really does peak
thomas thanks very much indeed
now let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now and new
zealand has recorded its warmest winter
ever which scientists there are
attributing to climate change
temperatures in june july and august
averaged at 9.8 degrees celsius now
that's 0.2 degrees higher than last
year's record but 1.3 degrees above the
long-term average
cop26 president alok sharma is in china
speaking to government officials about
climate change targets ahead of
november's cop 26 conference in glasgow
xi jin hua has been meeting with mr
sharma to discuss how the uk and china
will work together to ensure the summit
is successful
the greek government has created a new
ministry to address the impact that
climate change is having on the country
it comes after intense heat waves and
wildfires in parts of southern europe in
july and august
minister christos stelianides will head
the department which will cover
firefighting disaster relief and
policies to adapt to rising temperatures
hedgerows are being hailed as the unsung
heroes of climate protection new
research has suggested that investing in
them could be hugely beneficial to both
our climate and the economy
campaigners are calling for the
government to invest in hedgerows which
they say provide flood protection a
carbon sink protection for vulnerable
species as well as creating up to 25 000
jobs
and the uk is being urged to invest more
in artificial meat to help tackle the
climate crisis the social market
foundation says the industry needs rapid
expansion and the government should
encourage consumers to switch to meat
alternatives the official committee on
climate change says the amount of meat
we consume in the uk needs to be reduced
by more than a third by 2050.
and just to let you know that we're
going to be talking more about this
later in the show with our travel the
travel writer julia kinsman and guardian
columnist george monbio and they'll also
be discussing if live music is bad for
the environment and what can be done to
make festivals more sustainable
now europe's top 25 banks are failing on
their own green pledges that's the claim
today from the campaign group share
action which says the biggest banks are
still failing to present comprehensive
plans to address the climate crisis and
biodiversity loss despite having
sustainability pledges well with me now
is our euro correspondent adam parsons
so some sharp criticism for europe's
biggest banks adam any response
there are 25 uh banks listed here
including names that would be very
familiar to people barclays nat west hs
bc and indeed european names like like
paribas and ing and the report says
they're all on the start line but none
of them have started to run yet uh why
well it came up with four criteria which
were biodiversity exposure to high
carbon sectors policies restricting
services to services such as oil and gas
and linking executive pay to progress on
climate issues and it says that
effectively none of these banks
are making enough progress on all of
these categories the banks in response
say well hold on we didn't choose these
four categories you're judging us on we
are aiming uh for net zero by 2050 these
are the targets that have been laid out
to us
we're on the path towards them but share
action says you're not doing enough that
there are some outliers nat west comes
in for some praise at some point uh one
of only three banks which appears to
have ruled out future investment in
certain sectors but one area that the
report is very critical of is a lack of
response from europe's banks in ruling
out investment in yes you guessed it the
sort of fossil fuels that thomas was
just talking about why would that be
well one of the problems for europe is
this in the uk you might think coal is
obsolete you've been reflecting on that
but i've been recently to germany and
poland they are still using hugely uh
coal-fired power stations so i think
they'll be reluctant to say we're not
going to put any money into that that's
not saying no one has done but the big
banks might not turn their back on that
yet in other areas there are some banks
who say no we are not going to back any
projects that are for instance digging
up the arctic
but
all in all banks say look if you are
going to have an answer to the climate
crisis it's going to need us we are the
ones who supply huge amounts of
financing the bottom line i think at the
moment is that plenty in the climate
change activism world think banks don't
understand them and vice versa
adam thanks very much indeed
now the risks posed by climate change
could dwarf those of any single disease
that's the warning today from the
director-general of the world health
organization as part of a joint
editorial from more than 200 health
journals across the world
it calls for world leaders to take
emergency action to limit climate change
and protect health well the writers say
the urgent action is needed to keep
global warming below 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels and as you can see
on our data dashboard we're already at
more than 1.2 degrees of warming and as
you can see there that number is ticking
up the whole time so let's take a closer
look at what the editorial says so heat
related mortality destructive weather
events and the widespread degradation of
ecosystems essential to human health are
just a few of the impacts that experts
say we're seeing more of because of
climate change now these
disproportionately affect the most
vulnerable including children ethnic
minorities as well as those with
underlying health conditions
and the authors say that governments
need to intervene to do more for example
by supporting the redesign of transport
systems
cities production and distribution of
food and health systems now they claim
these investments will produce huge
benefits including more jobs reduced air
pollution
increased physical activity and improved
housing and better diets
the people we most want to implement are
the delegates at the united nations
general assembly which is is coming up
where countries will begin to or will
confirm their plans for cop26
so we want them to recognize that we're
not talking about the planet as a as a
abstract construct we're talking about
the the health and well-being and
survival of the people who live on that
planet
do stay with us coming up after the
break we'll be i'll be joined by the
travel writer juliet kinsman and george
monbiot from the guardian who i'm
pleased to say are standing by ready and
waiting we're going to be discussing
whether bands should stop touring and if
artificial meat could be the future of
your roast dinner that's coming up
[Music]
i would say there's a chance that she's
still alive and i know the germans have
called this a murder inquiry but i'm
going to stick with operation grange and
say it's a missing person's inquiry
still i was told there was a girl had
gone missing in portugal in in fact in
the algarve and a place i've never heard
of called predaluge
and uh i expected her to be found by the
time i actually got there um
you know obviously as you know that
hasn't happened but
when i first got there it was quite
clear that uh it was fairly haphazard
um
the search operation and um i think
you've seen a photograph there that i
took of the very flimsy not this one
you're looking at now but another one of
the gates i was able to walk up the
steps and actually pop in and even
introduce myself that's the one to the
family
and i didn't have a long chat with them
just to say hello because they were
actually due to go off to report a
missing person's
case at the the police station so i i
just said look i'll do everything i can
to help it looked very much like a
snatch from um um either alone or a
pedophile gang to order that had been
studying the apartment i think
having looked at this case now for 14
years as you say it looks to me like
there were people watching the apartment
and monitoring her when she was there i
think in my book i point out two blonde
head guys who were seen
literally an hour or two before she went
missing on a balcony below
or nearby very near the apartment and
nobody's ever come forward and worked
out who these two men were they were
seen by various people
i believe one of those was christian
bruckner who
is now the current prime suspect in the
case and uh as of june last year it's
been a kind of mad scramble to
understand
you know what he was doing there and how
he was able to live there for seven
years when he'd been convicted twice of
of child pornography and indeed of
molesting children in germany and
i had many many other
cases against him in fact i've traced 19
different convictions against him in my
book
and he was able to to live for seven
years in predaluge just just
less than a kilometer from the ocean
club
somehow the police didn't think he would
be of interest
to arrest and question
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
and the structure itself
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know that driving us to school
creates extra toxic air at drop-off and
pick-up times
tuesday looks like being a fine day for
most and extremely warm down in the
southeast as well temperatures reaching
anywhere between 28 and 30 degrees
celsius
that's 86 degrees fahrenheit there'll be
more in the way of cloud over scotland
but even here it should break at times
it's just the northern isles that stay
rather dull throughout the day so in
terms of air quality pollution remains
low for many parts of the country but
for england and wales it could be
moderate and in one or two areas we
could see that moderate level reaching
five or six
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
welcome back to the daily climate show
on sky news and we're getting straight
to discussing now the climate issues of
the day and challenge the solutions to
them with juliet kinsmen sustainability
editor of conde nast traveller and the
guardian columnist george monbio so a
very warm welcome to both of you really
nice to have you on the show thanks for
joining us
and we're starting talking about live
music because scientists from the
university of manchester have been
studying the band massive attacks latest
tour now they've used the data to come
up with a series of recommendations for
how to reduce the industry's carbon
footprint now the suggestions cover
everything from bands swapping private
jets for public trains to gig and
concert venues using renewable energy
and they think that fans should be
offered incentives to travel to events
by public transport so it's an
interesting issue this isn't it george
monbio but can live music and global
tours ever really be green when there's
so much power needed to power up the
venues and people need to travel
sometimes all around the world to get to
them
well in principle they could be pretty
good because if you think about it
you've got you know tens of thousands in
some cases even hundreds of thousands of
people coming to hear a handful of
people and it's only really the handful
of people who have to travel long
distances everyone else can come from
the local metropolis and so you could do
it in a really green and sustainable way
unfortunately it's often not done like
that and you know you see the aftermath
of festival sites with just disposable
tents scattered all over the place
massive emissions of people traveling to
them well full kudos to massive attack
for asking the climate scientists to do
an audit of their touring and to come up
with better ways of doing it and i think
what they've created here is a template
that other bands can now use and it
should become a global standard for
concerts yeah i'd be really interested
to see if any bands do get on the train
to get to their own gigs that'll be an
interesting one but julia the issue of
how the audience gets there is a big one
isn't it let's take a look here at one
of the facts that came out of the report
it said that audience travel makes up
the largest proportion of live music
related emissions so juliet should
people think twice about traveling to
gigs because of the impact on the planet
i think you'd be hard pushed to say to
people you can't go have your fun at a
festival because because of that i think
the words that you use that are so
relevant are incentivized and i think we
just generally as with any sector or
anything we're talking about in terms of
of looking at people's sort of emissions
is the transparency what if they could
have a certification
uh you know each band had some sort of
certification showing how much
they had either saved or how what their
carbon emissions were and and they had a
people could judge it like that and also
as george says you know really with
festivals it's it's about the wake and
all that disposability that's left and
as we know with the pandemic and covid
and the health and safety protocols
that's made it much much worse
um so i would just love to see
more transparency and and certification
marks across across everything whether
it's live music
in terms of
you know people's emissions
but but it's not just about transparency
is it george monbiot it's about actual
action you've got bands traveling all
around the world with a huge amount of
kit being transported as well i mean
they could just stream one live con con
to everybody couldn't they i mean should
we just clamp down on this
i mean i'm not against having live
events i think they're really important
they bring people together um and people
have got to have fun and you know god
knows we've spent enough time sitting
sitting in our own homes having
precarious fun so
but in principle it could be a pretty
low impact way to do it
you talk about trucking all that kit
around why why are bands trucking all
that kit around why don't they hire the
kit locally and you know help local
businesses by hiring the kit that they
have an offer and as massive attack
point out it's fundamentally the same
kit you know there's not a big
difference between the kit that you'll
truck halfway around the world and the
kit that you'll hire locally
and private jets absolutely out you know
i've seen i've seen too many bands talk
about all their green commitments and
how we recycle and how we do this and it
turns out that they travel by private
jet it's just outrageous and and i mean
i want to see all private jets banned
simple as that um so absolutely
minimize the emissions as much as
possible but let's not stop
live events because i think they're
really important particularly for young
people okay well let's talk about the
flying aspect george mobio they're
saying juliet we should ban private jets
what about the impact that flying has
this is very much your area i mean a
huge amount of carbon emissions one
flight from london to new york emits one
ton of co2 per passenger and they're
normally around 2500 flights every day
that is a huge amount do we need to do
something about that pretty promptly
absolutely i mean we all know that by
getting on a plane that's going to be
the biggest contribution to our own
personal footprints uh and i you know
only 11 of the world is is actually
flying and those who are suffering and
on the front line of the results of a
climate emergency are definitely not
those flying uh and i think it's really
important you know to remember that
you know the top one percent of the
world the ones who are taking the
private jets i've certainly never been
on a private jet that they're
responsible for for double the combined
carbon emissions of the poorest 50
so i think they're the ones we have to
look at and going back to when i said
you know the transparency and having the
certification imagine if everyone had to
wear you know what their personal
emissions were um and i think you know
in terms of aviation just to put it in
context though um
absolutely you know we should be flying
less i'm all for frequent flyer taxes
but if aviation as a sector were a
country it would only be the 20th uh
worst offending of all the countries in
the world so just to put it in context
um and and there's
obviously i advocate there's lots of
good that comes from international
travel it's it's just being mindful of
that we need it for wealth distribution
we need it because one in ten people in
the world is employed in tourism it's a
great way of sending money from the
countries and the people who have it to
those who don't okay we'll have a whole
other go on george i can see you're
dying to get in a very quick word before
we move on to the next section i mean i
mean as julia rightly says you know
there is this massive disparity in the
amount that people fly but it really is
worth emphasizing that the great
majority of flights not just on private
jets and ordinary jets are taken by very
rich people often to their second homes
often many times a year we need to tax
that very heavily with frequent flyer
taxes so that those who take a lot of
flights have to pay a lot of money for
it and that hopefully will discourage it
to a considerable extent okay well let's
move on to our next topic shall we and
we've heard earlier how the uk is being
urged to invest more into artificial
meat to help tackle the climate crisis
and we've been asking on social media if
you would swap out your burger for
lab-grown meat and around three-quarters
of you said that you wouldn't uh claudia
carter for example said she simply
doesn't if she doesn't simply doesn't
eat meat if she wants a vegetarian meal
instead of buying an artificially
produced substitute and if you want to
join the debate
please do use the hashtag
dailyclimateshow or you can tweet us at
sky news so julia what's your view on
this i know some people are turned off
by the idea of lab grown mead in fact
for example the french minister of
agriculture has said a meat comes from
life not laboratory so what's your take
on it
well i don't really have a petite i
certainly don't have a philosophical
feeling around it in that way i just i
look at the numbers and i think in terms
of practically speaking you know we're
almost at eight billion people on this
planet we're going to be at 10 billion
by 2050 those are a lot of mouths to
feed people need protein we need to do
it differently
and as we know you know
the the sort of
certainly the meat the dairy
particularly the beef
industry is responsible for so much
methane and i will you know i will say
actually you know eu's farm animals
produce more emissions than cars and
vans combined so you know we need to
find a better way of eating george
monbiot i know you've done a lot of work
in this area what difference do you
think that artificial meat could make
when it comes to tackling climate change
we could massively lower emissions i
mean i think the most important
technology actually is not so much the
artificial or cultured meat but it's the
it's a the feed stock that you use and
and precision fermentation using
bacteria to create proteins and fats um
bacteria which don't even need any
agricultural feedstock at all because um
for instance the ones which oxygenate
hydrogen
they don't need photosynthesis they're
basically just using carbon dioxide
water and electricity to make protein
and fat and you've minimized the land
area using hardly any land you're using
far lower resources to produce fat and
protein which can then be turned
into the million things that we eat
already plus a million things we haven't
even conceived of at the moment
and when you compare that to your
chicken broiler shed or your industrial
concentrated pork production with their
immense cruelty their really disgusting
nature swimming around in feces lots and
contamination you know really you know
that clean meat and the clean
substitutes for it it's very hard to see
how those are less appealing than than
the things they're meant to replace okay
well uh george monbiot and julia kinsman
really interesting debate i'm sure we'll
return to this subject in future as well
but for the moment thanks both very much
indeed for taking us through your views
on those areas
and that's everything from us for today
but coming up on the daily climate show
tomorrow as a public inquiry opens into
a proposed coal mine in cumbria we'll be
looking at whether fossil fuel projects
are putting the uk's leadership of the
crucial cop 26 climate summit at stake
that's coming up tomorrow do stay tuned
we've got lots coming up on sky news
tonight in just a moment with sarah
hewson the prime minister is set to
finalise controversial plans to fund
social care risking a major rebellion
inside the party
thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you